am freitag den 20 märz können wir hier
in europa eine sonnenfinsternis
beobachten was ihr dabei beobachten
sollte und worin der unterschied zu
einer mondfinsternis besteht das erfahrt
ihr jetzt bei pixum science fiction aus
dem deutschen museum in münchen
zwischen 9 und 12 uhr wird sich am
freitag unser neumond zwischen uns und
die sonne schieben je nördlicher ihr
dabei seid desto mehr licht blockiert
der mond während in münchen
immerhin etwas mehr als zwei drittel der
sonne nicht zu sehen sein werden wird im
norden deutschland bis zu 82 prozent der
sonne verdeckt ganz wichtig dabei ist
dass sie auf keinen fall mit dem bloßen
auge in die sonnenfinsternis gut selbst
bei einer totalen sonnenfinsternis die
am freitag nur auf wenigen inseln im
europäischen nordmeer zu sehen sein wird
kann direkter blickkontakt zu
dauerhaften schäden am auge führen
setzt euch also auf jeden fall eine
spezial verlauf aber worin besteht
eigentlich der unterschied zwischen
einer sonnen und einer mondfinsternis
bei einem normalen mond zu plus umkreis
der mond unserer erde und wird dabei je
nach position komplett teilweise oder
gar nicht von der sonne angestrahlt
dieses licht reflektiert der mond auf
die erde wo wir dann zum beispiel
sichern oder einen vollmond sehen für
einen vollmond muss der mond hinter der
erde stehen um das sonnenlicht auf der
kompletten er zugewandten fläche
reflektieren zu können
ungefähr alle sechs monate kommt es vor
dass der mond sich dabei gleichzeitig
auf der ebene der erdumlaufbahn befindet
wenn das passiert dann ist der mond in
unserem schatten
wir unterscheiden dabei zwischen einer
halbschatten mondfinsternis einer
partiellen mondfinsternis und einer
totalen mondfinsternis bei der
halbschatten mondfinsternis befindet
sich der mond im halbschatten
da die sonne keine punktförmigen
lichtquelle ist sondern eine fläche gibt
es einen bereich im schatten der erde in
dem der mond nicht das gesamte
sonnenlicht abbekommt eine solche
finsternis ist schwer zu erkennen da der
vollmond einfach nur etwas schwächer
leuchtet als sonst besser zu erkennen
ist das schon die partielle
mondfinsternis hierdurch kreuz der mond
zu einem teil den kernschatten der erde
dabei kann man den rand der erde als
schatten auf dem mond sehen schon die
griechen der antike schlossen daraus
dass die erde rund sein musste wenn der
mond nun komplett in den kernschatten
der erde ein taucht dann erhält er kein
direktes licht von der sonne mehr
trotzdem leuchte der und zwar blutrot
warum ist das so ein teil des
sonnenlichts
auf den mond immer noch und zwar wird
das licht durch die atmosphäre der erde
gebrochen es macht quasi einen bogen um
die erde herum unsere atmosphäre
absorbiert dabei verschiedene
wellenlängen des lichts und deshalb
sieht der mond für uns rothaus das
geschieht sehr selten
ein solcher totale mondfinsternis langer
dauer also über 100 minuten kommt nur
ungefähr alle 10 bis 20 jahre vor
die nächste könnte im juli 2018
beobachten also so lange müsst ihr nicht
mehr warten
außerdem wurde mir noch eine spannende
frage gestellt kann es theoretisch eine
ewige sonnenfinsternis geben und wenn ja
welche auswirkungen hätte das auf die
erde hier moment könnte es natürlich
nicht passieren
dazu müsste der mond mit uns um die
sonne fliegen damit er immer zwischen
uns und der sonne stehen könnte außerdem
dürfte die erde auch nicht rotieren da
der schatten den der mond auf die erde
wirft sich sonst über die erde hinweg
bewegen würde
die auswirkungen wären aber wenn es
passieren würde je nach größe des bundes
drastisch ähnlich dem gewaltigen
meteoriten einschlag der womöglich durch
seine staubwolke die sonne verdeckte und
die dinosaurier getötet hat könnte auch
eine ewige sonnenfinsternis eine riesige
klimatische veränderung bedeuten am
freitag werdet ihr merken wie es schon
nach einer kurze stunde sonnenfinsternis
merklich kühler wird die wird es dann
erst nach jahren aussehen eine
dauerhafte eiszeit könnte die folge sein
eine super möglichkeit die
sonnenfinsternis übrigens zu beobachten
gibt es hier im deutschen museum in
münchen
dort gibt es eine sternwarte und dort
die wird speziell vorbereitet auf diese
sonnenfinsternis werden spezielle filter
eingebaut damit man direkt in die sonne
gucken kann das sieht dann ungefähr so
aus und da kann man ganz genau sehen wie
sich der mond vor die sonne schiebt also
hier im deutschen museum könnte das ganz
toll beobachten
heute gibt es noch mehr spannende videos
zur sonnenfinsternis wenn ihr auf den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
klickt kommt ihr zu einer playlist in
der ihr alle videos findest das simple
physik erklärt hier
ob die sonnenfinsternis für
stromausfälle sorgen kann und alles
physik zeigt euch hier den unterschied
zwischen einer totalen und einer
partiellen
finsternis werdet ihr euch das
astronomische spektakel am freitag
angucken wenn ja wo schreibt es mir
unten in die kommentare
bis dann bleibt dran